[Music]
the man
the myth the legend santa claus is one
of the most iconic figures on the planet
santa used to be number one on the
forbes fictional 15
but her mailbox is filled up with
letters from angry kids whose
christmases we ruined and we were forced
to eliminate them from the fictional
list
santa israel they overwhelmingly wrote
and so we sent a reporter on one big
mission
if santa is real then go prove it and he
went straight to the source
santa father christmas chris kringle
whatever you may call him was born a
beardless baby in turkey in the 4th
century
he wasn't like the other naughty kids in
his village he was a saint
literally saint nicholas as he would
come to be known after his death
became famous for his generosity after
he saved three young women from a life
of ill repute
their wealthy father had fallen on hard
times and couldn't afford their dowries
so nicholas on three successive knights
threw a purse filled with gold coins
through their window where it
miraculously landed in their stockings
drying above the fire now he just gives
rudolph a set of ps5s and calls it a
night
santa first received widespread
attention in 1823
when clement seymour a prominent new
yorker wrote a christmas poem for his
nine kids
beginning with the line was the night
before christmas
it was there santa discovered lox bagels
and pizza slices that are only a dollar
he grew a few belt sizes but never lost
the weight
turns out mrs claus likes dad bods from
there the legend took off
now santa runs a multi-conglomerate off
international waters
he employs over 25 000 elves ranging
from private detectives to slave traffic
controllers
over the years santa realized something
about himself
he really liked being famous over the
past 200 years he's shamelessly chilled
for
well anything one of his biggest deals
was his lifetime exclusive with
coca-cola but
he frequently violates his contract and
has even been seen in pepsi commercials
he earns residuals from his appearances
in tv film and music
and has a team of aggressive elves that
sue those who use his image and likeness
without permission
after all these years of traveling the
globe exhausted the now 1700 year old
has
finally settled in the north pole with
his wife and a few thousand elves
it's there that they run their magical
reindeer preserve
we estimate that santa is the richest
man in the world which tends to bring
comparisons to the world's other
packaging delivering magnate
jeff bezos santa wrote to forbes and
said that while he appreciates the press
he despises the comparisons to jeff
bezos and wants to make something
very clear jeff is not santa 2.0
yes amazon stole the idea of cheap labor
yes
amazon copied his corporate tax
loopholes and yes
amazon may know who's naughty or nice
but they're cheating
you